Would a true friend leave their
pal behind in a hot steam tunnel?
With rats? Apparently to die? Some "Big Bang
Theory" fans say the answer is a clear "no."
Here's the scene that has them steaming mad.
While "The Big Bang Theory" may be a comedy,
its 12 seasons include a few
moments capable of inciting
strong, angry reactions from some viewers.
Many of these scenes happen to involve Raj
Koothrappali and his poor treatment at the hands
of those closest to him throughout the series.
"I thought we were best friends!"
"We are! That's why I'm sad my
best friend's gonna be homeless."
At first glance, Raj and his science-minded
buddies Sheldon Cooper, Leonard Hofstadter,
and Howard Wolowitz appear to be a tight-knit
foursome. On numerous occasions, however,
Raj is made to feel left out from the group.
This is especially true when Sheldon, Leonard,
and Howard begin dating Amy Farrah Fowler, Penny,
and Bernadette Rostenkowski, respectively. Before
long, they then start abandoning Raj to
spend more time with their girlfriends.
Raj, on the other hand, has horrible luck
with women. One romantic interest of his
even climbed out of a window to escape
from him on a date. If that wasn't enough,
"The Big Bang Theory" concludes with each of
its main characters enjoying a happy ending,
except for Raj, that is. Though he revels
in bringing "Buffy the Vampire Slayer" star
Sarah Michelle Gellar to Sheldon and Amy's
Nobel Prize ceremony, she sets the terms:
"Just to be clear, this isn't a date."
"I know."
"Then why are you holding my hand?"
While fans of Raj surely feel for him in
each of these and similar occurrences,
one particular conflict between him and
Sheldon had his fans truly seeing red.
In an episode in the eighth season, Sheldon and
Raj aspire to participate in a government-funded
experiment on dark matter. As it turns
out, it involves staying in a tiny,
100-degree-fahrenheit salt mine for
a total of 12 hours. To prepare,
Sheldon and Raj conduct a simulation
within the steam tunnels of CalTech.
Though Sheldon walks confidently into the
experience, he quickly becomes claustrophobic
once it's underway. Raj then tries to calm him
by recounting the history of "Hannah Montana."
"...but then she would take off her wig
and go to school like a normal girl,
which I don't have to tell you,
at that age, is its own headache."
Sheldon's breaking point comes 11 minutes into the
ordeal, when he spots two massive rats behind Raj,
prompting him to abruptly leave his supposed
friend behind. Sheldon flees upstairs,
slams the tunnel's door shut, and informs
lookout Amy that it's "too late" for Raj.
The episode ends with a sweaty,
frazzled Raj confronting Sheldon:
"You call yourself a friend?
I was trying to help you and at the
first sign of trouble, you ran away!"
A number of fans were angered by the CalTech steam
tunnel situation after watching
it unfold. One Redditor wrote,
"I feel like they treated Raj like
s--- for a lot of the show. His dad
was right in the last season when he told
him his friendship with them was toxic."
Another wrote,
"[Sheldon] doesn't just leave him there
he actually closes the metal hatch door."
Another Redditor pointed out that Amy
doesn't even attempt to reopen the hatch
door and help Raj escape, despite
seeming fully capable of doing so.
Contrary to his character's poor treatment
on "The Big Bang Theory," actor Kunal Nayyar,
who played Raj, has assured fans that
he and the real-life cast of "The Big
Bang Theory" are on good terms. Speaking to
HeyUGuys, Nayyar had nothing but the highest
praise for his fellow cast members and his
experience on the hit CBS sitcom on the whole.
"We're a family and we've got each
other's backs. We have from day one."